[Applaudissements]
pensons une personnalité ou un fil il
est seul vous êtes contrôlés alors
essayez de qui qui va donner la réponse
beaucoup plus fort que vous choisissez
achète aller collectivement c'est parti
on joue alors attention chez vous vous
êtes prêts on cherche une chanson est
allégué faut que tu dises ça c'était
parti quelle est cette chanson parce
qu'il n'avait pas encore bien saisi le
passé on à dire gg voilà c'était le
banana split de lio attention autant
intéressante on cherche un pipole
regarde c'est pas tellement les max vous
savez quoi je n'ai pas la réponse
je suis dans la meilleure c'est très
très compliqué quand même si je les sais
pas ça c'est pas nous
[Applaudissements]
non il faudrait qu'on équilibre un peu
quand même mais la menace était
tellement vous savez qui est là oui bien
sûr je suis arrivé je faisais où il
devrait y arriver attention généreuse de
1 partout pour un film chez vous un film
essayer de retrouver un film c'est parti
figure alors à votre avis qu'est ce que
c'est ça en battant donc on dort en bas
l'assassinât
l'aubergine moussaka alors le berger
l'espagne a ouai c'est le premier point
pour l'exil doit quatrième cette fois ci
on cherche une chanson alors c'est une
presque chansons des partis c'est déjà
pas facile
casse noisette meyrinois casque à casque
noir
serra
c'est castellano a bien joué voilà c'est
fait peur comme ça quand on vit dans
cette émission d'ailleurs je doute
possible la question quand on est invité
qu'on sait pourquoi on vient déjà veut
on revient parce que vous êtes déjà venu
et pour 8,7 qu'on aime bien on est
content de les revoir
voilà un jour de ton petit cadeau pour
vous que eric elle vous fera en vidéo
donc commencer at on jugé pour quoi on
joue
ben alors j'aurai peut-être des images
de nadège on joue pour un film à
regarder un film toujours chouchou
chouchou j'ai dit ça c'est un jeu qui
pourrait être sûr idée c'est vrai elle
joint pour une chanson à l'essai pour
vous là alex je vous fais une super
promo si vous le trouvez oliva chansons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour pour un film regardé à vous
trouver
non mais là on est allé alex un fil
antibes la citrouille la grande russie
de la grande six trous c'est pas mal
c'est là qu'est ce qu'on voit fenêtre
sur cour est passé mais c'était
connaître surtout évidemment
je vais rentrer chez me alex je sais
qu'elle est sûre et roger des téléphones
en rester là c'est sympa balle et j'ai
regardé les textos si vous voulez
loutraki soleil d'allah et bien tout
c'est le vôtre si vous voulez qu'ils les
élections ou pas mais il peut citer les
ingrédients à yako alors on y va pour le
7ème on cherche maintenant un autre film
c'est parti alors est ce que c'est un
rasta
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]